in New York at the UN headquarters
Sunrise brought news of President
Putin's words and his threats
he had spoken while leaders and
delegates here at the annual General
Assembly were asleep and from the early
arrivals prime minister what'd you make
of Vladimir Putin's comments this
morning Canada
the European Union is it time for NATO
to double down for the EU to Double Down
he's talking about nuclear war now sir
turkey what should NATO do now this
wasn't the moment for off the cuff
remarks statements came Western nations
in Universal condemnation of Russia no
real change there it was the day though
for the American president to deliver
his key speech well here he is arriving
just now a little later than planned and
with a speech that has been altered as a
consequence of what Mr Putin has been
saying
and from the podium he was blunt and he
was firm this war
is about extinguishing Ukraine's right
to exist as a state
plain and simple
and Ukraine's right to exist as a people
whoever you are
wherever you live
whatever you believe
that should not that should make your
blood run cold
because if Nations can pursue their
Imperial Ambitions without consequences
then we put at risk everything is very
institution stands for everything on the
specifics of the Russian nuclear threat
he had this we do not seek conflict
we do not seek a cold war
a nuclear war
cannot be won
and must never be fought
then from the chamber to the first
meeting with prime minister truss
Ukraine the focus of course but an
interesting hint of other challenges
ahead and finally we both are committed
to protecting the gains of the Good
Friday agreement in Northern Ireland I'm
looking forward to hearing what's on
your mind and how we can continue to
cooperate
America's laser eye on Northern Ireland
is a problem for Liz truss and in this
moment at least the special relationship
didn't feel particularly warm
there are always distractions but the
core Focus Ukraine is ever more
challenging and frightening Mark Stone
Sky News at the United Nations